so wait so this is my favorite story
that I've heard about you because I
heard that you it was you were doing
music and everything but it just wasn't
hitting like you wanted it wasn't
hitting you got a big huge family and I
heard that you this could be wrong but
you were at Costco and you were shopping
whatever for all your family with a lot
of kids and so and is it someone that
came up to you and asked for an
autograph oh yeah and then you ended up
working for Costco yeah this guy he came
up to me and he wanted my autograph on
his napkin and he mentioned you know
that he he worked at Costco in the tire
center and I needed an overnight job and
um you know I was just like I was
embarrassed because he wanted he wanted
to be a musician also and I was like
it's not that fun man you know and then
I was like by the way I was like if I
give you your this autograph can you put
in a good word for me at Costco and we
honestly at first he was a little like
dang you know and then but we became
buddies yeah and um can I tell you like
that and that is real like everybody
thinks American Idol that was my first
thing I ever did and it wasn't you
literally I had like four jobs to
maintain living here and trying to make
it and people don't get that because
their pride and ego get in the way and
it's like you know what you just need to
provide like that's a grown ass man
and it's so unbelievable and I feel like
that's why good things happen to people
whoa that put that out in the universe
you know my family they were always
supportive my kids didn't ever know you
know that they don't care whether you're
poor you know yeah they're happy and
then my wife Laney
um you know she never never at one time
was like Hey this dream's a bad idea you
know she just she just was glad that I
loved what I did yeah you know and
supported that was that was fine you
know it was enough for her and so you
know she she wrote me a note every
single morning I went to to work at
Costco I would leave the house at three
and there was always a letter and like a
lunch I mean she you know and I it was
it was amazing and when she she was so
supportive that year of my life and so
yeah I'm glad in that now you know I can
buy our dogs named Puckett and
um yeah it's cool but it's just the
greatest story because people think you
hit like are you you're in the music
industry and it just all of a sudden
every door opens and it doesn't like
right off the bat you you have to work
and you have to do things that you like
aren't really what you want to be doing
but you do them because you've got to
pay electricity like for that and water
and all the things and I just love it
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]